[موسيقى]
الحب هو اهم عامل
للابداع
الحب واحد يحب بلاده مثل مثل البلاد ومثل
محمد بن عيسى حولها حولها لمزار عالمي
خريطه الفنانين التشكيليين خريطه الشعراء
خريطه الباحثين
[موسيقى]
ونواصل هذه الجوله مع الحروف والتشكيد
خالد الساعي هنا في هذه المدينه اصيله حيث
التقيته في ورشتها الفنيه
يبحر فيها عوالم الحرف ويكتب على جدار
المدينه انه عبر من هنا وذلك عبر لوحه
تليق بالمدينه
[موسيقى]
نواصل هذا التشبع مع خالد في ازقتها وفي
ضواحل الحرف في متنه في هوامشه في تجلياته
المتعدده وفي خطوطه الكثيره
انت درست في اسطنبول يعني تخصصت باسطنبول
تخصصت بالخط التقليدي الخاص
لماذا اسطنبول لانه فيها مدارس يعني لنكن
منصفين
او اكثر عم نحكي مثلا انا اخذت من استاذي
علي اولد ارسلان اللي هو اخذ من استاذ
حليم بيك اللي اخذ هو نذهب الى المدرسه
نذهب الى عمق الف الف ومتين سنه او اكثر
فهذا شيء ليس سهل هذا والتاصيل الحرف
وتدريس الحرف بشكل اكاديمي عندهم موجود
وليس موجود
بالحرف العربي وهم يعني بيكتبوا بحرف
لاتيني يعني تركيا موضوع مختلف وشائك لانه
كل شخص له مرجعيته
الملتزمون مثلا يتجهون الى الخط التقليدي
اما مثلا
العلمانيون
والحداثيويون عندهم قطيعه مع الحرف لانه
يريدون الانسلاق عن كل ما سبق يعني كل شيء
يذكرهم بهذا الموروث هم بغنوا لكن قسم
كبير من الاتراك ينظر الى الحرف بقدسيه
الان يعني عندما يرى لوحه فهو امام نص
مقدس ان كان حتى لو لم يكن النص ديني
خلينا نحكي شوي عن انت لمحت في الحوار عن
عن الموسيقى والخط انت لك علاقه بالموسيقى
يعني تعرف شوي بس فقط سماع لكن عندي اظن
شيء اشتغلت على الموسيقى لانه عاش معي
اكثر من مره عازفين موسيقيين واخي موسيقي
واللي شابني هو انه الحرف هو موسيقى
عندما جرى تثبيت الحرب جرت تثبيته على
اساس الصوتيات وعلى اساس الحركات مثلا
الثاء والتاء والكذا بمعنى انه الحرف كشكل
وكحجم وكصوت يتوازيه مساحه معينه فمثلا
الحرف الباء هو
انطلق من نقطه من النقطه تحت هو لفظ من
منطقه معينه شو فيها يعني
هي نفس المكان لكن هي من اعلى نفضت النقطه
الزمنين ثلاثه نقاط فاذا هو موسيقى وهو
هي الزمن يعني صوت عبر الزمن فهذا هذا
الشيء بعثت دفعني الى الشغل اكثر بالتلازم
بدون شك يعني مجرد ما تتامل بالحرف العربي
في بعد كوني وبعد بصري خالص يعني فقط
يحتاج الى مخيل خصبي لحتى يبني عليها مثلا
لو
فكرنا في حرف الباء تجد كانه قارب صغير
على نقطه ومش جالس عليها
في منطقه من الجاذبيه تفصيل يعني في
جاذبيه متساويه وكلمه قارب اخرها حرف
الباء فهو الباء نون هو هذا جميل لانه
وعاء الى هذا توصيل جميل لكن في شيء خلينا
نقول بفقه الحرف ابعد من هذا الشيء يعني
تغيير هيئه الحرف وهذا غير موجود باي لغه
حرف الهاء المفرد مختلف عن الهاء
الابتدائيه والهاء الوسطي والنهائي اذا
الحرف
متحرك
ومتبدل حسب موضعه وهي لا يوجد باي لغه
والهاء هو حرف مثل ما حكينا هو حرف هوائي
وهو حرف سمعي شوف حركه الهاء التفافه مثل
كانه عندما
نستقبل حلزون
في حين العين هو من العين العين والخنجر
والحاجب عندما نوصفها بالحرف نقول عين
الحرف او الحاجب للعين يعني بدون شك انت
يعني مفتون بهذا العالم وقال لها ما
اشتغلت ما اثرك الى هذا الحد
مين من الحروف العرب او غير العرب اللي هم
شكلوا لالك نوع من الهيكل انه فتحوا امامك
شيء تاملت في تجربتهم وفي منهم بيشتغلوا
على الحرف بدون معنى يعني بدون ما ياخذون
نص له معنى مثل المهداوي مثلا المهداوي
يعني لا تقرا نص تقرا لوحه فيها حروف
اصلاح اعطيك مقاربه مقاربه الصوت يعني او
الشعر الشعر هو كلام مفهوم له تاويله لكن
عندما يغني مغني الاوبرا هو ياخذ اللغه
الى مكان اخر صحيح فاذا نزل مهداوي اخذها
الى هذا ذلك يعني التعامل مثل ما نقول
البحتري هو شاعر خالص فايضا يوجد حروفيون
خالصون
على لغه الحرف وليس على اللغه صحيح لغه
الحرب بمعنى جرد الحرف اخذوا الى مواطن
الحرف صار يقول قوله الخاص فتبعا لكل شخص
يعطي تاويل او يعطي قراءته
بمعنى انه الحرف قادر ان يوصل رساله خارج
اللغه
خارج اللغه يعني ينفك من اللغوي ويتحول
الى لغه الخط هو بالانجليزي لاين وليس خط
العربي للاسف عندها نقطه هي الخط بمعنى
الخط مستقيم اولا والخط بمعنى فن الخط في
الانجليزي يختلف هذا الشيء يوجد غير خط
كذا فهذا مبحث مهم فيوجد عدم الحروفين
اخذوا الحرب في هذا الاتجاه بهذا الاتجاه
ويوجد ناس يشتغلوا على اتجاه الكتابه
حرروه من اسر المعنى في الكلمه اذا فينا
نسميها هيك يعني لكن بضل عندما تنظر اليه
بتحس في نوع من القدسيه باللي بيشتغلوا
حروفيات
هل هذا مرتبط بذاكرتنا التي تتعلق بالنص
خاصه بالنصوص المقدسه اللي هي مشغوله بهذا
الاطار يعني حتى زخرفيا مشغوله من الاطار
الحرف ممارسه روحيه
والحرف ممارسه ايضا مقدسه ارتبطت بفتره
طويله بالنص الديني وبالنص العرفاني وحتى
اللغه ككل اللغه اخذت هذا النوع من
التبجيل يعني العامل على اللغه والمثقف
وليس شخص عادي تخيل مثلا بفتره معينه كان
الخطاط لا يمكن ان يكتب دون ان يتوضا يعني
كانه يتجه الى صلاه
يتجه الى صلاه يعني فهذا الوصال مع الحرف
هو انقطاع عن العالم وتواصل مع الخالق طيب
ماذا عن غير المسلمين الذين
يصنعون خط جميل جدا يعني حروفين رائعين
زبون الى الصلاه صلاه جميل الفكره يعني
فيها طقس صلاه القلب يعني هي هي الجلال
والقدسيه اللي يفرضها الحرف وايضا على
الممارس يعطي سكينه وهدوء عاليه جدا
طيب افتكرت انه هذا الحرف الذي تعمل عليه
الان وحرف عربي ولكن له ايضا ذاكره مختلفه
عن اللغه عن الشكل الذي وصل اليه
بحثت في هذا المطرح انه ذهبت الى مصدر هذا
الحرف في في ذاكرته في تاريخه بالطبيعه
الحال اشتغلت كثير على هذا الموضوع لكن
يعني كلغه العربيه انحدرت من الاراميه
اللغه الام
فهناك تناسبه بعض اشكال الحروب في ناس
بيقولوا
النبطيه يعني بتكوين تكوين اخر الى لكن
لنكون واضحين يعني اكثر بالفتره العباسيه
اللي جرى فيها تقاعد الحرف وتثبيت اشكال
الحروف ان كان اهم مخاض يعني
لهندسه الحرف
وتحويله الى لغه فعلا اكاديميه وصوتيا
يعني مثلا اذا دخلنا بتكوين حرف اللي
اخذناه الباء الباء مر بعده مخابرات
واشكال حتى حتى وجدت شيفره ناظمه لكل لكن
مثل ما حكيت القصه هي بعهد الخطاط الشهيره
بالمقلى او الخلق الخطاط والباحث والشاعر
والموسيقي ابن مقلى هو اوجد اول منظومه
اللي هي الخط المنسوب فنسب الحروف الى
دائره ووضع الالف هي قطر الدائره اللي هي
الانسان بطوله الكامل يعني هي مقاربه مع
الانسان
شغل عليه ليونيرد دافنشي في الانسان الرجل
اللي
فالمخمس يعني
بابعاد الخنسفه
الف في قطر الالف هي قطر الدائره وبطول
سبعه نقاط وعند الانسان
هو سبعه رؤوس فما معنى النقطه هي الراس
سابق نعم عمل دراسه امانه عن هذا الموضوع
هي مقارنه بين الاثنين لكن هي هواجس تنتاب
كل العالم اذا كانت الالف اللي صار انا
عندي رغده انا اعرف اذا الالف في قطر
الدائره ماذا عن بقيه الحروف يعني تاخذ
اجزاء من الدائره اجزاء فيقول يكون في بعض
الحروف مثل التاليه يسمى حرف منكب في حرف
مستلقي في حرف راجع في حرف مضطجع فيعني
تتكلم عن هيئات الحروف يعني يعني مثلا انا
اردت حرف ج
كما يقول النفري والحرف يسري حيث القصد
جيم جنه جيم جحيم او جيم جهنم بمعنى ممكن
تاخذه الى الاقصى الى من الاقصى الى
الاقصى فيوجد نقضين يعني
هذا الشخص ايضا هو يعلم في الموسيقى
وشاعر هو شاعر كونه شاعر موسيقي يعني فينا
نقول هو انجز معرفه كامله او ابتكر او سبت
شكل الحرف كما ينبغي ان يكون واضاف الكثير
اضاف الكثير حتى باطلاع الواسع على علم
الفلك يعني
ساهم ايضا
باسقاطات عجيبه على الحرف والنجوم والحرف
والسماء والكواكب فكان بحث عميق جدا يعني
بالنتيجه يعني اوصل الحرف الى مفهوم مفهوم
كوني وليس مفهوم فقط
مرتبط
بشيء مادي او شيء موسيقي
مذهل هذا العالم عالم الحرف والمذهل ان
عالما كمثل ابن بقله اهدانا حياه كامله
بعد اشتغالاته على تثبيت هذا الحرف اهدانا
معنى كاملا هكذا من دائرته الكونيه شاركنا
سر الحرف ومسراه فهذا الفلك والموسيقي
واللغوي والعالم ندين له بكل ما كتبناه من
فكر وابداع واسئله وتامل
[موسيقى]
ثري الحرف العربي ثري في شكله وتحولاته
والملفت الاخر فيه هو تعدد الخطوط التي
يكتب بها هو امه كما قال ابن عربي ولكن
هذا الحرف الامه
المنحدر من دائره ابن مقله والقادم من
منبت ارمي ونبطي يكتب في اكثر من شكل وخط
متحول الوثابت الكوفي والمسند والنسخ
والثلث والرقعه والديوان الى اخره لا توجد
لغه في العالم تحتمل هذا الثراء والتنوع
في الشكل والتحول ولكل حرف عالم مستقل
ومتصل له بعده الموسيقي الكوني الروحي
والمعرفي والهندسي
قد يبدو لدى البعض في خطوطه المتعدده
معقدا الى حد ما
تصعب قراءته وهذا لانه موضل في بعده البصر
تصبح له هذه الشخصيه المتمنعه
يعني هي ليست تعقيدات هي
تجليات جماليه تنوع وغنى بالحرف
وهذا الغنى له عده اسباب يعني احد الاسباب
انتقال الحرف من حاضره الى حاضره يعني
لنقل القاهره هي اوجدت او كرست انواع الخط
الكوفي فخرج عنا الكوفي المملوكي والكوفي
الفاطمي بمعنى انه الحرف هو صوره
وارتساب
لفتره معينه وهو شكلها البصري
بدمشق اوجد النسخ واوجدت خطوط اخرى في
بغداد وجدت خط الثلث ونسب الى الدائره في
الفتره العثمانيه اوجدوا عده خطوط الرقعه
والديواني واخر وفي بلاد فارس ووجدوا خط
التعليق فاذا كل بيئه
افرزت نوع خط يشبهها
لما جاء الخط الى المغرب العربي ايضا
افرزت خطوط اخرى ملفتك انه في دمشق ونس
الاساس طبيعي يعني هو بلش في عند الحقبه
الامويه اظن يعني تبلور بالحقبه الامويه
يعني ارادوا ان يعني ان الناس تقرا في
جميعا يعني تخيل انه من الحرف عندما تقرا
مخطوط تعرف انه هذا الحرف جاء من نيسابور
من هذه المنطقه من هذه الفتره هذا لا يوجد
باي لغه اخرى لانه فن لكن ارجع لسؤالك
الاول الاول وهو لماذا الخط معقد ولا يقرا
ولا يقرا ولكن لا يقرا عند الجميع طيب
الجواب هو عندما ترى اي تلتقي باي اوروبي
الان هو قادر ان يستمتع باللوحه التجريديه
وحتى اللوحه المفاهيميه واللوحه الاخرى
عنده وعي بصري وعنده تكوين تربوي واضح
بالعالم العربي لا يوجد هذا الشيء يعني
انا مره حضرت لقاء احد الممثلين الكبار
يعني سؤال سالوه عدد ثلاثه انواع الخطوط
العربي الخط العربي لم يتمكن يعني
جهد ممكن صفحتين يقراها الفرد ممكن تساهم
بانه تنوروا شوي عن هذا الفن فهي مساله
تربويه وحتى شخصيه احيانا التقي باوروبا
يعرف الخط الكوفي من المسند من الريحان في
خط اسمه الريحان جميل
فهذا التقصير وليس يعني نعم
لا تطلب من اي احد يعرف لوحه سلفادور
داليا او يفهم لا هو الخط يعني لانه هو
ينقل نص الخط بينقل لك نص طيب وهذا النص
له معنى وهذا المعنى يطمح لشيء يعني يطمح
للوصول الى شيء معين يعني المفروض يقولون
الناس صح انا هذا هو جوهر سوداني قديما
كان الكل يقرا هذا
لاجل ذلك اتى النسخ وتعودت عليه تعود علي
البصر هاي القيمه الوظيفيه للحرف نعم
لماذا اخترع خط الرقعه لسهوله الكتابه صح
هذا المقصود بو ضوح الكتابه والنسخ اخذ
الخط الرسمي المقروء اما الفن فشيء اخر
[موسيقى]
بدون شك بحكم تجوالك ربما كل مكان كل مكان
او كل مدينه طالما عم نحكي عن الخط وايضا
يعني يملي عليك يملي عليك
لوحه معينه في التعامل مع الخط ومع الحرف
مع اللون مثل ما شاهدنا الان في اصيله
جداريه يعني الجداريه بتشبه اصيله بشكل من
الاشكال فيها بحر وفيها الوانه وفيها
الازرق وفيها فيها المناخات كلها
هل هذا صحيح انه الامكنه ايضا تفرض على
بشتغل خاصه بهالمطرح بالنسبه لي صحيح هذا
مئه بالمئه صحيح يعني اللوحه باصيله هي
تشبه اصيله هي بنت اصيله لو بمكان اخر
ممكن خرج معي شيء اخر مختلف وامانه بزياره
الاولى لاصيله عملت لوحه هي صباح في اصيله
فكان يبدو هذا القصر الذي نحن فيه
شامخ بالوسط وحوله الكتابات تطوف ف المكان
بصريا ووجدانيا
يلهم الفنان طيب واين الذاكره ماذا بقي
منها في هذا في شغلك بتحضر الذاكره
الامكنه الاولى امكنه الطفوله امكنه
النشاه يعني تلك الالوان تلك الصوتيات تلك
الحروف يعني اطياف الاشياء يعني تلقي
بظلالها على عملي لكن الحضور للواقع هو هو
يعني ممكن احيانا اشتغل على استحضار شيء
معين يعني بعملي اللي عملته بكم سنه
بالبرغمون بمتحف برلين عن سوريا حديقه
التاريخ اضطريت لانه استرجع سوريا كامله
استرجع تاريخ 7000 سنه بعمل فني طبعا عمل
كان يعني له وقع عجيب وكبير وكان يعني كان
المفروض مني يعني ارجع اعيد صياغه هذا
التاريخ بتلازم الصوره والحرف طبعا على
مستوى الموسيقى حكينا عن الموسيقى ولكن
الذي يعني
يجذبك في الموسيقى يعني هي
اي مناخات المناخات العربيه المقامات
الموسيقيه العربيه ام الاشكال الاخرى من
الموسيقى العالميه من الاوبرا او الموسيقى
الكلاسيكيه
السوناتا
اما ربما الحروفيات والشغل والحرف هو اقرب
الى
الى زائقه السمعي العربيه بشكل عام هو
فعلا هو
اقربائك العربيه هو مثل
يعني
وفي قيم جزله بالبناء الموسيقي فهذا يطلع
مع خط الثلث بينما النهونت اوصاف الاصوات
هذا يروح مع خط الديوان الجلي في
انسيابيات وفي اشياء حلوه مثلا خط التعليق
او الفارسي تسميه
ركيكه هو التعليق يذهب مع مقام الحجاز
وقام روحاني سلس سهل فلما ترى خط التعليق
هكذا لما تتجه لسيجا السيجا بنوعيه يعني
كان ايقاعي ولا خفيف فتشوفوا يتجلى بشكل
قطعي يذهب مع الخط السنبلي
[موسيقى]
فتره اقامتي بامريكا يعني
ذهبت كثير الى الجهاز البلوز عميق وجميل
بس شو بيطلع معك بيطلع معك شيء
طلع اعمال غريبه ومغيره ما هو الجهاز ونوع
من الارتجال قريبا العربيه ولكن
حل اخر التوليدات الصوتيه حلوه بالجاز
والارتجالات ايضا فيها نوع من المغامره
[موسيقى]
التحدي بالنسبه لي وهذه المغامره والتحدي
والارتجالاتي
انت تقوم بها باللوحه اظن يعني انت ما
بيكون عندك تصور كامل الى اين تذهب التصور
المنتهي صارت رياضيات معادله اما التصور
اللوحه الشراره الاولى احيانا تبدا بشيء
وتنتهي بشيء احيانا تكون بفكره معينه لكن
التجلي يوصلك الى مرحله ابعد يعني وقتها
نقول الحمد لله
لكن احيانا احيانا بعض الاع تتطلب دراسه
وخصوصا اعمال ثقيله وكبيره لكن انا احيانا
كثيره عن تمد على على الشراره الاولى نعم
كانها تضيء لي الطريق وامشي بهذا الطريق
واحيانا شو اللي يحدث انه تطلع نتيجه
معينه بعدها لا يرضيني هذا الشيء ابدا مره
اخرى اعمل لوحه اخرى فتخرج مجموعه من فكره
معينه فالمجموعه ككل وليس واحده تمثل
الفكره اللي اشتغلت عليها
كان هذا الابحار مع خالد الساعي في بحور
الحرف العربي
بحيث
يدهشك في تحولاته واحتمالاته وتاويلاته
يدهشك بسره وسحره
نترك خالد هنا في هذه المدينه يستعد لرحيل
اخر
[موسيقى]